La pequeña Shannon, a la izquierda,
está mucho mejor,
y Ryan consiguió un empleo por formarse en algunos de nuestros cursos.
¿Qué hizo estos cursos tan diferentes?
Si bien los cursos en línea han estado disponibles durante un tiempo
la diferencia estuvo en que estos recreaban la experiencia de una clase real.
Empezaban en un día determinado,
los estudiantes veían los videos sobre una base semanal
y se les asignaban tareas.
Tareas reales con valor para una calificación real
y una fecha de entrega definida.
Aquí ven las fechas límite y el gráfico de uso del sitio.
Estos picos demuestran
que el posponer es un fenómeno global.
(Risas)
Al final del curso
los estudiantes recibieron un certificado.
Lo podían presentar a un posible empleador
para obtener un mejor empleo,
y conocemos a muchos que lo hicieron.
Algunos lo presentaron
en su institución educativa
para validar créditos.
Así que los estudiantes obtuvieron algo valioso
a cambio de su tiempo y esfuerzo.
Ahora hablemos sobre algunos componentes
de estos cursos.
El primero es que cuando se dejan atrás
las restricciones físicas del aula
y se diseñan contenidos explícitamente para una clase virtual,
se puede escapar, por ejemplo,
del inflexible formato de una hora.
Puedes fraccionar el material, por ejemplo,
en unidades cortas de entre 8 y 12 minutos,
que constituyen cada una un concepto coherente.
Los estudiantes pueden revisar el material de diferentes formas,
dependiendo de sus conocimientos previos, habilidades e intereses.
Por ejemplo, algunos se benefician
del material preparatorio
que otros ya conocen.
Otros pueden estar interesados en un tema particular
que quieren seguir de forma individual.
Este formato nos permite abandonar
el modelo educativo en que todo es igual para todos
y permite a los estudiantes seguir un currículo más personalizado.
Por supuesto, como educadores sabemos
que no se aprende viendo videos de forma pasiva.
Quizá uno de los mayores componentes del proyecto
es que necesitamos tener estudiantes
que practiquen con el material
para asegurar su comprensión.
Numerosos estudios han demostrado la importancia de esto.
Este, que apareció en Science el año pasado, por ejemplo,
demuestra que incluso el simple repaso de retención,
que consiste en solo repetir
lo aprendido,
produce una mejora considerable en los resultados
de varias pruebas de rendimiento,
superando otro tipo de intervenciones didácticas.
Tratamos de incorporar el repaso de retención,
entre otras formas de práctica.
Por ejemplo, nuestros videos son más que videos.
Cada pocos minutos hay una pausa
y se plantea una pregunta.
(Video) SP: …Teoría de la perspectiva, descuento hiperbólico,
sesgo del statu quo y sesgo de conocimiento previo,
son desviaciones cognoscitivas bien documentadas del pensamiento racional.
DK: Aquí viene una pausa,
el estudiante escribe su respuesta en el recuadro
y la envía. Obviamente no puso atención.
(Risas)
Así que intenta de nuevo
y esta vez acierta.
Si lo desea, puede revisar la explicación.
Ahora el video continúa.
Esa fue una pregunta fácil
de las que yo podría hacer en clase,
pero cuando las hago,
el 80 % de los alumnos
aún está anotando lo último que dije,
el 15 % está distraído en Facebook,
y el sabelotodo de enfrente
grita la respuesta
antes de que el resto pueda reflexionarla.
Y yo estoy muy complacida
de que alguien haya sabido la respuesta.
La clase continúa y la mayoría ni siquiera nota
que hice una pregunta.
Aquí, cada estudiante
debe interactuar con el contenido.
Desde luego, hay mucho más que
estas simples preguntas.
Se deben incorporar ejercicios más significativos
y retroalimentar a los estudiantes
en todos ellos.
¿Cómo calificar el trabajo de 100 000 estudiantes
si no se tienen 10 000 asistentes?
La respuesta es dejar a la tecnología
hacerlo por ti.
Y por fortuna, la tecnología ahora nos permite
evaluar una diversidad interesante de tareas.
Además de las preguntas de opción múltiple
y de respuesta corta como la que mostré,
podemos evaluar expresiones
y derivaciones matemáticas.
Podemos calificar modelos, bien sean
financieros en una clase de negocios,
o físicos en una clase de ciencias o ingeniería,
y también ejercicios sofisticados de programación.
Les mostraré uno sencillo,
pero muy visual.
Es de la clase Ciencias de la Computación 101, de Stanford.
Los estudiantes deben corregir el color
de esta imagen roja borrosa.
Escriben su programa dentro del explorador,
pero no muy bien, la Estatua de la Libertad aún parece enferma.
Así que intentan de nuevo y lo logran,
y ahora pueden ir al siguiente ejercicio.
Esta posibilidad de interactuar activamente con el material
y recibir evaluación inmediata
es esencial para el aprendizaje.
Aunque aún no podemos evaluar por completo
las actividades que se requieren en todos los cursos.
En especial, faltan las actividades de pensamiento crítico,
tan esenciales en disciplinas como
las humanidades, las ciencias sociales y los negocios.
Intentamos convencer a algunos profesores
de humanidades, de que las preguntas
de opción múltiple, no eran tan mala estrategia.
Pero no funcionó bien.
Tuvimos que idear otra solución,
y llegamos a la evaluación por pares.
De acuerdo a estudios previos,
como este de Saddler y Good,
la evaluación por pares es una estrategia efectiva
para conseguir calificaciones reproducibles.
Solo se ha usado en clases pequeñas,
pero se demostró, por ejemplo,
que las calificaciones asignadas por alumnos, en el eje Y,
están muy bien correlacionadas
con la calificación asignada por el maestro, en el eje X.
Aún más sorprendente es que las calificaciones autoasignadas,
cuando los mismos estudiantes calificaron su trabajo,
—en tanto los incentivos sean apropiados
y no puedan asignarse una calificación perfecta—
tuvieran aún mejor correlación con la calificación asignada por el maestro.
Así que ésta es una estrategia efectiva
para calificar a gran escala
y también para enriquecer el aprendizaje,
pues los estudiantes aprenden de la experiencia.
Contamos con el mayor sistema de evaluación por pares jamás concebido,
decenas de miles de estudiantes
están calificando el trabajo de sus compañeros
y exitosamente, hay que decirlo.
Pero no se trata de tenerlos
aislados en un cuarto resolviendo problemas.
En cada curso se formó
una comunidad de estudiantes.
Son comunidades globales
que comparten un esfuerzo intelectual.
Aquí ven un mapa generado
por los estudiantes del curso Sociología 101, de Princeton,
donde marcaron su localización en un planisferio.
Pueden apreciar el alcance global de la iniciativa.
Los estudiantes colaboraron entre ellos de varias formas.
Primero, había un foro de preguntas y respuestas,
donde algunos estudiantes planteaban sus dudas
y otros las respondían.
Lo maravilloso es que,
debido a la gran cantidad de alumnos,
si alguno hacía una pregunta
a las 3 de la madrugada,
en alguna parte del mundo
alguien estaba despierto
y trabajando en el mismo problema.
Por lo que en muchos de nuestros cursos
el tiempo de respuesta promedio
en el foro, era de 22 minutos.
Es un nivel de servicio que nunca he ofrecido a mis alumnos en Stanford.
(Risas)
Y pueden ver por sus testimonios, que
estos estudiantes creen
que debido a esta gran comunidad en línea,
pudieron interactuar unos con otros en varias formas
más profundas que las que habían tenido en un aula.
Además, los estudiantes se organizaron
sin nuestra intervención
en pequeños grupos de estudio.
Algunos se establecieron físicamente
a partir de limitaciones geográficas,
y se reunían cada semana a trabajar en los problemas.
Éste es el grupo de San Francisco,
pero los había en todo el mundo.
Otros grupos eran virtuales,
centrados alrededor de un idioma u otro elemento cultural.
Y abajo, a la izquierda,
pueden ver el grupo multicultural,
cuyos miembros deseaban explícitamente interactuar
con personas de otras culturas.
Hay enormes oportunidades
en este tipo de contexto.
Primero, tiene el potencial de darnos
una mirada sin precedente
en el entendimiento del aprendizaje,
porque podemos recopilar información única.
Se pueden recopilar todos los clics, tareas
y entradas en el foro, de decenas de miles de estudiantes.
Así, el estudio del aprendizaje puede pasar
de estar fundamentado en hipótesis
a estar fundamentado en datos, un cambio que,
por ejemplo, revolucionó la biología.
Los datos pueden ayudar a responder preguntas fundamentales,
como qué estrategias de aprendizaje
son efectivas y cuáles no.
Y para cada curso particular
se pueden preguntar cosas
como, cuáles son las equivocaciones más comunes
y cómo ayudar a los estudiantes a corregirlas.
Aquí hay un ejemplo,
también de la clase de Aprendizaje automático,
es la distribución de respuestas erróneas
de una de las tareas.
Las respuestas vinieron a ser pares de números,
por lo que se pudieron graficar en dos ejes.
Cada pequeña cruz es una respuesta errada diferente.
La grande de arriba
es de 2000 estudiantes
que cometieron exactamente el mismo error.
Ahora, si dos estudiantes en una clase de 100
cometen el mismo error,
puedes no percibirlo.
Pero cuando se trata de 2000 estudiantes,
es imposible ignorarlo.
Andrew y sus estudiantes
revisaron algunas de las tareas
para entender la causa de la equivocación
y elaboraron una explicación específica
que enviaron a quienes
daban esa respuesta equivocada,
y así los estudiantes que cometían ese error
recibían retroalimentación personalizada
indicándoles de manera efectiva cómo corregirlo.
Esta personalización es posible gracias a
la gran cantidad de información recopilada.
La personalización representa
una de las mayores oportunidades aquí,
porque nos da la posibilidad
de resolver un problema de 30 años.
En 1984, el investigador educacional, Benjamin Bloom
planteó el llamado problema de las dos sigmas,
que observó al estudiar tres grupos de estudiantes.
El primero estudiaba en un aula tradicional, a base de conferencias.
El segundo también estudiaba
a base de conferencias,
pero con un enfoque dirigido a objetivos,
de tal forma que los estudiantes no avanzaban
sin antes dominar el tema anterior.
Y en el último grupo, un tutor daba
instrucción individual a los estudiantes.
El grupo basado en aprendizaje dirigido a objetivos obtuvo
una desviación estándar o una sigma, por encima del rendimiento
del grupo corriente con clases basadas en conferencias.
Y la instrucción individual produjo
una mejora de dos sigmas en el rendimiento.
Para entender qué significa,
veamos la clase basada en conferencias
y tomemos el valor medio como umbral.
Así, en la clase basada en conferencias,
la mitad está por encima de ese nivel y la otra mitad por debajo.
En el caso de la instrucción individual,
el 98 % estará por encima de ese nivel.
Imaginen lograr que el 98 % de los estudiantes
superara ese promedio.
De aquí el problema de las dos sigmas,
dado que no podemos costear, como sociedad,
el darle a cada estudiante un tutor humano individual.
Pero quizá podamos darles
una computadora o un teléfono inteligente.
La pregunta es, ¿cómo usar la tecnología
para ir de la zona izquierda, de la curva azul,
a la zona derecha de la curva verde?
Es fácil dominar un tema usando una computadora,
porque esta no se cansa
de repetir el mismo video cinco veces,
ni siquiera de calificar una actividad muchas veces,
como les he mostrado en muchos de los ejemplos.
Incluso estamos viendo
los inicios de la instrucción personalizada,
bien sea a través del currículo
o de la retroalimentación personalizada.
La meta aquí es probar, impulsar
y ver cuánto nos acercamos a la curva verde.
Así que, si esto es tan bueno, ¿son obsoletas las universidades?
Bueno, así lo creía Mark Twain,
quien dijo: "La universidad es el lugar donde los apuntes del profesor
van directo a los del estudiante,
sin pasar por el cerebro de ninguno de ellos".
(Risas)
Sin embargo, me permito disentir de Mark Twain.
Creo que lo que criticaba no eran las universidades,
sino las clases basadas en conferencias
a las que estas dedican gran parte del tiempo.
Así que retrocedamos, hasta Plutarco,
quien dijo: " La mente no es un vaso por llenar,
sino una lámpara por encender".
Quizá debamos dedicar menos tiempo
a llenar de conferencias las mentes de los estudiantes
y dedicar más tiempo a encender su creatividad,
su imaginación y sus habilidades de resolución de problemas,
a partir de la interacción genuina con ellos.
¿Cómo lograrlo?
Lo hacemos adoptando el aprendizaje activo.
Numerosos estudios, incluyendo éste,
demuestran que si se emplea el aprendizaje activo,
interactuando con los estudiantes en el aula,
mejoran todos los indicadores de rendimiento:
asistencia, compromiso y aprendizaje
medidos en exámenes estandarizados.
Pueden ver que, por ejemplo, el nivel de logro
mejora hasta el doble en este experimento.
Quizá así debamos usar el tiempo en las universidades.
En resumen, si pudiéramos ofrecer educación de calidad
a todos en el mundo, gratuitamente,
¿Qué supondría esto? Tres cosas.
Primero, la educación se establecería como un derecho fundamental.
Cualquier persona en el mundo
con la capacidad y la motivación,
podría desarrollar las habilidades que necesitara
para mejorar autónomamente su calidad de vida,
la de su familia y su comunidad.
Segundo, permitiría el aprendizaje continuo.
Es una lástima que para muchos el aprendizaje termine
al completar la escuela secundaria o la universidad.
Al tener disponible esta asombrosa colección de cursos,
es posible aprender algo nuevo
cuando se desee,
ya sea para expandir nuestras mentes
o para cambiar nuestras vidas.
Por último, impulsaría una ola de innovación,
porque en todas partes hay talento asombroso.
Quizá el próximo Albert Einstein o el próximo Steve Jobs
viva en una villa remota en África.
Y si pudiéramos ofrecerle una educación,
podría ser capaz de producir la nueva gran idea
y hacer del mundo un lugar mejor para todos nosotros.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)